[Music]
hey guys do you always compare yourself
to other people if you're
comparing yourself to your role models
because you want to improve yourself
it's not a bad thing it might be a very
good thing i'm talking about comparing
yourself to other people and letting it
influence your life negatively thinking
things like my hair does not look as
good as that guy or my coughs are not as
big i'm not as smart as her i'm not as
rich i'm not as cool i'm not as funny
not as good with people and on and on
and on these kind of thoughts let you
start to think man i must not be worth
that much
these thoughts
comparing yourself to other people it's
a waste of time listen carefully because
it is stopping you from focusing on your
own unique race in this life not only
that it is also creating low self-esteem
and you need to stop it starting today
there's a quote that says do not
underestimate yourself by comparing
yourself with others it is our
differences that make us unique and
define just how special we are
you know it is strange
how many people are going to such
extreme lengths you know doing certain
things just to try and fit in with a
certain group of people
while we were created to be unique
meaning you were made to stand out
to be different to be unique there has
never been a you before you and there
will never be a you after you there is
only you
it's as plain and simple as that
so run your own race
every second you spent wishing you were
like someone else is the second you
waste on your own life
did you get that this is important i'm
gonna say it again every second
you spend wishing you were someone else
is the second you waste on your own life
because you were never meant to be
someone else you are meant to be you
start today and stop comparing yourself
to other people or your life to someone
else's social media platform because
you're comparing your life to their
highlights and most of the time their
highlights are fake just created to
boast or pretend on social media you
know we live in a day and age where
truth is hard to find
especially on social media people lie
so you hear these stories you see them
oh this happened or i did this or i did
that and then you believe it so here you
are comparing your own talents your own
genes or even your career to someone
else's story
while not even realizing that it is a
lie
according to custard a british digital
marketing company
over 75 percent of brits admitted to
lying on their social media profiles in
a survey of two thousand brits and only
eighteen percent of men and nineteen
percent of women reported that their
facebook page displayed a completely
accurate reflection of who they are
most commonly participants said that
they only shared non-boring aspects of
their lives and were not as active as
their social media accounts appeared
i'll say it again truth in this world
in this day nature we live in is
extremely hard to find focus on yourself
you only start to live your own life
when you start to focus
truthfully
on yourself to have self-awareness
accepting yourself as you are
knowing
both
your strengths and your weaknesses
lawrence bossidy said self-awareness
gives you the capacity to learn from
your mistakes
as well as your successes it enables you
to keep growing
you don't ignore your weaknesses no
but you look at them and you work at
yourself on yourself to improve your
weaknesses you take responsibility for
yourself for your own decisions for your
own actions and this requires deep
personal honesty you have to be honest
with yourself
no excuses
no blaming other people
you take responsibility for your own
life everything that you do and say
you own your mistakes and you learn from
them by doing only three things
one
admit it
two
learn from it three
never repeat it again
you know there are certain things truths
in this world that will never change
because truth does not change
and if you
don't
accept truth
if you believe a lie
only two things will happen
number one your perception of truth
won't change reality
two if you don't accept it you will
always feel unstable in this world
truth is truth the sky will always be
blue gravity will always be gravity
if i take my phone if i leave it what's
gonna happen it's gonna fall
another truth is you were meant to be
you you're not meant to be someone else
so it's time to take an honest look at
yourself in the mirror and accept
yourself as you are
because only then will be able to start
to live your own life and
improve yourself
jordan peterson said
don't compare yourself with other people
compare yourself with who you were
yesterday
other people are not your competition
you are in a competition with yourself
so focus on your own race stop comparing
yourself with other people to see if you
are a great person rather compare
yourself to the truth
the bible
man it is one of the best books that
i've ever read
showing me my true identity is like
looking in a mirror
and also answering so many of the
questions that i had and i'm still
growing i'm still improving
if you want to grow if you want to
improve then start reading your bible
and you can also watch one of these
videos here from my other channel and
we'll help you
and before you go always remember guys
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys